so you just learned how to make a
hamburger menu which is pretty darn cool
so I want you to think about what that
means for your site layouts and
transitions I want you to pretend that
you're developing a website with an off
canvas navigation menu when a user
clicks on the hamburger icon a nav
element should show up alongside some
main content on mobile viewports though
the nav isn't going to be visible until
these are actually makes that click take
a look at the CSS here which handles the
nav menus transition from hidden to
visible this open class is going to be
applied on clique which means when user
clicks on the hamburger menu this class
will be applied which of the following
four diagrams accurately shows what's
going on in them the gray box represents
the viewport the blueish purple-ish box
represents a nav menu and of course
there's site content inside so pick the
diagram best represented by the CSS here